Mom Dad any what values were injected
like give us a paint a picture of what
values were injected growing up in the
two of you guys was it hey you got to
work hard hey you got to respect people
hey you know you got to read books what
what were some of the values my my dad
he worked two jobs he was a barber and
he worked at this um
at this uh took like it was Fieldcrest
it's like a textile mill and uh he was
never home because he always had two
jobs and my mom was like really
Christian and she always told us to do
the right thing and never do drugs or
you'll wind up like your cousin he's on
drugs and you don't want to be like them
so but but my dad he worked really hard
actually one of his jobs eventually
killed him he caught some
um disease that has worked from
breathing in Cotton yeah and it killed
him how old were you guys he actually
died on my 14th birthday on your 14 how
did that affect you guys
man it was terrible it was it was rough
yeah I mean um it's been so long ago but
um and then I had an older brother who
went into the military so that was
somebody else to look up to and um
a lot of my friends looking back on it
didn't have no dads yeah
I didn't realize it at the time but all
my close friends all my close black
friends none of them they had a mom they
had a grandma yeah no dad I never
noticed any of that stuff but when I
look back on it at least I had a dad I
think that's what kept us in line wow
because a lot of those guys stay uh
unfortunate for them they got locked up
you know and was there a relationship
with pops were you guys close for the 14
years like was there any kind of like
you played sports schedule my daddy yeah
he's a big guy he's mean well so he
didn't really daddy didn't really talk
much the only time you saw Daddy's when
you [ __ ] up and he was beating your
ass and he would beat our ass what if we
oh man like old school or no old school
Daddy was alive today doing this [ __ ]
he'd be locked up you can't do this
what's the running back that got in
trouble for whooping his kids uh oh and
uh Peterson yeah he made Peterson like
the pope you know he got knocked out
last week by the way Peterson did he
voted against the belt Le'Veon uh love
you on Bill Le'Veon Bell was the other
running back yeah he knocked up Peterson
can we uh can we stay here on this Dad
concept yeah because we just came back
from Madrid we were interviewing Andrew
Tate I'm sure you're familiar with him
and a major focal point of the interview
was uh the role of a father the role of
a man the role of uh what Andrew Tates
that the influence he had over him and
his brother the role that Pat's dad
Gabriel uh had over him and you said
that your dad passed away when you were
14 but he was a badass dude would whoop
your ass all that yeah but you
appreciated the fact that at least you
had a father you're talking about the
fact that all your friends didn't even
have a father you'd even realize it yeah
meaning it was just completely normal in
your lifestyle right right and then when
did this Epiphany hit you and like what
happened to all your friends that didn't
have fathers I think this is something
that young men are lacking these days a
male influence a male figure leadership
go ahead you know what my dad really
didn't talk much but I saw what he did
each and every day that was a huge
influence for me what my dad had to go
through as far as working jobs and I
think that's very important for just men
in general because if you don't have a
father figure in your life you're going
to be like a woman actually if that's
who's raising you you're gonna be like
an angry woman yeah women are typically
emotional and you don't want your men to
be emotional that's like a that's like a
nightmare for men yeah and as far as my
mom she really battled with a lot of
self-confidence because my mom she grew
up during Jim Crow so by the time I was
an adult and I was 18 I was traumatized
about white people being racist because
that's what she endured when she was a
grown-up because she actually lived
through Jim Crow and all that what would
she what would she tell you guys so hey
Keith Kevin just make sure when you're
going on the streets that when you go to
school if the white man what what were
some of the mindsets that were instilled
in you with what specifically well my
mama for the most part was traumatized
by racism everything she looked at was
through a lens of black versus white
because that's what she experienced next
time so when when I graduate and I went
to school and when I went on to the
military I looked at white people
totally different than what I do now
because I heard all the horrors growing
up as a kid yeah I lost my father he
wasn't in my life but my mother's in my
life but what she instilled in US is
just fear of racism so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]